Bonjour à tous! Alors ce que je vais vous montrer maintenant c'est un teaser d'une vidéo très
particulière que je vous prépare depuis des mois. C'est une vidéo pour fêter mes 10 millions d'abonnés
YouTube un court métrage réalisé par Ludovik. Ca fait vraiment des mois que je travaille dans cette petite fiction
j'investis beaucoup de temps là dedans donc j'espère que vous allez vraiment..
euh..apprécier. J'ai pas trop envie de le spoiler ou d'en dire trop donc je m'arrête là je vous montre juste quelques images. Si vous êtes
impatient comme moi que ça sorte de mettre un petit «J'aime» sur le top. Voilà pour me montrer un peu votre puissance et me donner la force
et puis nous on se revoit très très bientôt sur le YouTube français. Ciao!
(🎵  Musique de suspense🎵 )
*Ahem* Euh...
Bonjour je viens parce qu'en fait j'ai un problème—
Ne parle pas au YouTubeur.
Désolé, je ne peux rien faire pour vous maintenant laissez moi j'ai du travail.
D'accord
Ecouter il parait que vous êtes le spécialiste.
Moi, le compteur de ma chaîne youtube est bloqué et je sais plus quoi faire.
À combien?
9 999 999
Vous avez dit, combien?
COURS NORMAN COURS!!!!!
Norman, es-tu prêt à pénétrer dans ta chaîne YouTube?
Ouais.
Et si on le chute, ta chaîne YouTube sera à jamais supprimé.
Là-bas, la vidéo «Faire les courses». Allons-y!
Tu as vu «Matrix 2»?
Euh...oui.
Ce n'est pas pareil.
Ah, d'accord.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne YouTube de Norman!